Well, hello, everyone. My name is Dave Kehr.
I'm a curator in the Department of Film here
at the Museum of Modern Art,
and I'd like to welcome you all to this little chat.
We're sitting here in the Titus 1 Theater
at MoMA,
which is where we have most of our film screenings.
It opened in 1939 when this building did,
so it is now the oldest continuously operating
movie theater in New York City.
And probably through this conversation you'll
hear a little rumbling in the background,
and that is the sound of the oldest continuously
operating subway in New York City,
which is located right on the other side of
the wall here.
So nothing wrong there, just turn down your
woofers and we should be fine.
Today we're gonna answer your questions about
the film department
and what it means to be a curator of film.
We got quite a few questions on the other
videos we've posted here
and we're gonna start with some of those.
And our producers will pass me your questions
as they come in,
so let's get to the first one.
And it's the big question, Heather Malcolmess,
susebbentley, and nesin have all asked
more or less the same question.
It's, "How do I become a film curator?"
I think the good news is there is no answer
to that question.
There is no real career path, educational
path to this particular job.
I came from almost 40 years as a film critic
writing for daily newspapers
when the film department contacted me
and asked if I'd be interested in coming aboard.
We have other members of the department who
have started here as assistants and have gradually
worked their way up the ladder.
We have other people who were trained at some
of the archival programs at NYU or Rochester
and have entered that way.
It's a funny kind of job in that I don't think there are a lot of jobs like it in this country.
MoMA is very generous in that they consider
the film curator job to be analogous to a
curator's job in painting or sculpture,
so we have a great deal of latitude about
what kind of scholarship we wanna do,
what kind of programming we wanna do,
what kind of research we wanna do.
Yeah, it's been a wonderful opportunity for
me and I certainly hope that
people who have a passion for this kind of work
are willing to pursue it and hopefully will
restore the ranks of film curators in the future.
The only bit of advice I've ever had to offer
anybody who have asked me about
writing about film or curating film is that it's,
like so many things in life, it's all about practice and repetition.
I think you develop your taste as a critic
by watching as many movies as you possibly can,
and you develop your writing skills by writing
as much as you possibly can.
I'm not sure if these are things that can
be taught as much as they can be learned
through trial and error.
It takes a while to develop a sensibility
and it's something that no one can give to you.
It's not a subtle thing.
You have to arrive at that point yourself
through your own reflections,
through your own experience, through your own understanding,
so it's different for everyone.
Yeah, let's see what else we might have here.
And indeed, Ginerva of YouTube asks,
"If there is a specific path of studies that
I should undertake in university in order
to become a film curator?"
And indeed, I think a good background in film
history is definitely a must.
Depending on what branch you wanna go into
there are certainly more technical pursuits.
If you're interested in film preservation
that's a very distinct branch,
working with the film elements, with the nitrate film,
with the negatives.
That's something you can learn and probably
should learn in a university environment.
There are a number of programs around the
country, UCLA, USC, Rochester, Indiana,
all of them producing very fine people in that field.
But if you're interested in more of the programming
side, I think, again, it's a question of,
developing your taste, seeing what you can,
writing what you can, being able to make a...
learn how to make a good argument,
which is something a lot of people need to
learn.
It's not always about having opinions,
it's about justifying your opinions and being
able to share them with other people
and convince them that what you wanna do makes sense.
It's a wonderful field and one that's treated
me very well,
and I wish I had a secret password that would
open the door and you could jump right in,
but I'm afraid there just isn't one.
This is something that I almost feel that
the hand of fate came down and tapped me on
the shoulder to do this,
and it's just not the kind of thing I ever
really thought I would be doing,
but I certainly consider myself very, very lucky to be doing it now.
Let's see, well, dmayer o n Instagram wants
to know what did I study in university?
And indeed, I did not study film.
I am actually so old that there were no film
programs when I was at college in the
University of Chicago.
I studied English as an undergraduate and
had a passionate interest in film.
We had a very active film society on campus
which is still there, Doc Films,
University of Chicago.
And that was just a terrific opportunity,
again, to see a lot of movies.
We showed films I think five nights a week,
often double features.
In the days mostly what we were getting was
on 16 millimeter, so there was a very wide
selection of movies available at that time.
And it was, yeah, an unguided education in
the sense that I didn't have a professor
telling me what to look at.
But there was plenty of literature available,
as there certainly still is,
and I think the best thing to do is just to
plunge in and follow your nose
and see where it leads.
You never know where you're gonna end up.
Indeed.
Here's a tricky one from Tug Nadley on YouTube.
"What do you see as television's role in film
history?
Does the MoMA collection contain any content from the small screen?
And as new content delivery programs like
Netflix continue to blur the lines between
weekly series and single films thanks to binge
watching,
do you think that television programs will
become more prominent in film history?"
Well, that's a lot of questions there, and
these are things that we
are still struggling with on a daily basis.
MoMA has some television but it's never really
been part of our method,
at least up until now to collect television.
This is the oldest, first archive in the world
that started collecting film as an art form
back in 1935,
so we very much evolved from that sort of
theatrical film perspective.
When television started coming into the '50s,
it just wasn't something that the museum was
collecting,
unfortunately, because an awful lot of '50s
television is now lost.
And as we've gone on it's more that we've
collected television work by
directors who were basically known for their theatrical films.
In New York we have The Museum of Broadcasting.
They have a wonderful collection of kinescopes
from that period.
UCLA has a fabulous television collection in Los Angeles.
But just not something that the MoMA has been
much involved in,
but that's certainly something we have to think about.
And as you say, theatrical film and streaming
are starting to converge.
There's a lot of overlap and we're seeing
a lot of
very interesting work by theatrical directors working in that new long-form format.
They got a lot of new talents coming up through
the long-form format who have really never
made a feature-length film.
So definitely something we need to consider
as we go forward,
and I'm sure we will start looking to that kind of work more seriously.
Inevitably, you know, that kind of format,
the extended series, is gonna become more important.
It seems like people are starting to lose
the habit of going out to see a
90-minute, 2-hour self-contained narrative film in the
theater
and they're more and more staying home and
watching these long-form fictions.
That's gonna change the way we think about
film and television,
and the beauty of a department like this is
that we are able to grow and develop as the
medium grows and develops.
So I think we just have to stay tuned and
see where things go,
but definitely that's a major shift in our medium right now
and it's something that MoMA is gonna have to
deal with very seriously in the years to
come.
Let's see...well a YouTube question from Eva.
"Hi Dave! You were a critic before becoming
a curator.
How did writing about films first inform or shape your curatorial work?"
I've had a line about that for a while is
that
curating is the extension of criticism by other means.
It's another way of expressing your opinion,
another way of making an argument,
I think, to put together a program that suggests
a particular point of view.
Yeah, it's definitely always using your critical
judgment as a curator.
At the same time, you don't wanna rely entirely
on your own taste.
You have to be open to other people's suggestions,
try to give an overview of something that you're focused on.
We recently did a program of early '30s films
from the Fox Film Corporation,
and that's a collection that consists of a
lot of important films by major directors,
like John Ford, and Howard Hawks, and William
K. Howard,
and also consists of a lot of silly comedies
and musicals that have no particular
authorial stamp on them.
And yet, those are certainly fun to watch
and worthwhile seeing,
and we're glad to bring those back and find them an audience when we can.
So rather than just being a strict didactic
about it, these are the important films.
I like to also get into some of the unimportant
films, some of the marginal stuff,
some of the mere entertainment that people
were also watching at that time.
I think we just got something off the live
line from Tree Island Horror on YouTube.
"Hi Dave, have you ever acted in a film before?
Did you ever want to work behind or in front of the camera?"
I have never acted in a film and I can't imagine
that opportunity is going to come up.
I have worked on two documentaries, television
documentaries,
one about Clint Eastwood and one about the director Budd Boetticher.
But yeah, from early on it was never...filmmaking
was not for me.
I was always more of a film watcher, more
of an analytical mind than a creative mind.
And I've never really felt that pull to do
that.
You know, my talents are such as they are,
seemed aligned in another direction,
so I pretty much stuck with that for the course
of my career.
And let's see...Instagram from Michael Paul
Phillips.
"Are there particular techniques and/or aesthetics
you look for in a film to be featured at MoMA?"
Well, no really.
Yeah, the trick is to be open to as many possibilities
as you can while still maintaining,
I guess, a sense of quality and relevance.
The last thing you wanna do is have a checklist
in your mind,
"A movie has to do this, this, and this in order to be a good movie."
Francois Truffaut once said that every great
film defines its own aesthetic, and I
agree with that.
What makes an Orson Welles film great is not
what makes an Ida Lupino film great.
Director has an idea of the cinema to them
and their films are the explication of that idea.
More and more we're seeing directors who rely
on heavily digital techniques,
the possibility of taking an image apart and putting
it back together in ways that
previous generations of filmmakers just...
it just wasn't available to them.
So that's a huge shift in aesthetics, and
one that I've kind of struggled with.
The point at which heavily digital special
effects film really becomes something closer
to animation than a live-action film,
still something that nags at me.
I don't have a clear sense of where I stand
on that myself.
But again, I think the important thing is
to be open to those developments and recognize
them when they come
and not get attached to one particular notion
of this is a movie, everything else is not.
Let's see, what else?
From Instagram, elmapetersone asks, "From
your point of view, how important is the role of a curator
in movie art saving or popularization?"
Certainly in saving films we play a pretty
important role.
When MoMA started in 1935 there really weren't
any programs in place to preserve old movies.
The studios had their vaults but often they allowed
things to disintegrate.
A lot of movies were lost.
It really took Iris Barry, who was the first
chief curator in the film department here
to say she wanted to pluck these films, kind
of, out of that flow of product.
There are certain movies that deserve to be
kept, preserved, restored, treasured.
And because she did that, and because she
did that on such a wide scale,
a lot of important movies have survived that
would not have survived if Iris Barry weren't there
to pick them up.
For example, we have pretty much every film
that the Biograph Studios made
between 1909 and 1914
because Iris went and bought the negatives
when Biograph went out of business in 1939.
So we have amazingly good copies of some of
the most important films by D. W. Griffith.
That was a collection that yielded what we
believe is the first full-length movie to
star an all-Black cast, a film called "The
Lime-Kiln Club,"
starring a vaudeville comedian named Bert
Williams.
We found that we had the rushes, unedited
rushes for that film
were in the Biograph collection.
And when my fellow curators, Ron Magliozzi
and Peter Williamson,
put that footage back together,
it produced a 15-minute feature-length film,
which would've been absolutely the first one of its kind
and the last kind for several years.
And in that case, that's something we've now
made available for loans to other museums
and we hope to get that out on Blu-ray one
of these days.
For popularizing a film, I don't know.
We kind of intervene after the
fact after a movie has had its commercial career.
We do have a number of programs here, like
the New Directors, New Films show that premiers
new films,
hopefully movies that are going onto a commercial
career.
So we can help to some degree by drawing attention
to movies that we like,
but I don't think that's something that the
museum can really influence on a substantial scale.
I mean, that really has to roll out, and it's the judgment of the public and the judgement of the audience.
There's not a great deal we can do to promote
things after we show them.
Wish there were, but you know, that's the
role of critics, again, the role of
fans and an audience is to support this work.
And we're always happy to return to them.
There are lots of movies that were misunderstood
on their first release and it's nice to come
back in the context of the museum show
and give them another look because they can
look quite different 5 or 10 years later.
It's something that happens all the time,
and that's what we're here to do.
Let's see, another live question from Morgan
B on YouTube.
"Is there one lost film in particular you
wish could be salvaged and viewed?"
Oh boy, that's a hard question to answer and
I think everyone would have
a different response to that.
I'm gonna name something you've probably never
heard of which is a film by Josef von Sternberg,
who you may know from his films with Marlene
Dietrich.
One of his last silent films called "The Case
of Lena Smith," made in 1928.
One of the last silent films released by Paramount.
We only have about 10 minutes of it but those
10 minutes look absolutely sublime.
And if I had one movie I could make magically
reappear I think it would be "The Case of Lena Smith,"
but, you know, you have a wide
range of opinion there.
"London After Midnight" is one that a lot
of people mention.
Certainly we'd like to have the complete original
cut of Orson Welles "Magnificent Ambersons."
Unfortunately there's just too many choices
there.
There are a lot of things that have been lost
and we just...
the temptation is to concentrate on what we've lost rather than what we have.
I prefer to think about what we have and able
to work with these films,
work with damaged elements,
work with dirty negatives, scratched prints
to clean them up and send them back into the
world again in a nice, new form.
There is certainly no shortage of things that
we can dig into the archives and relaunch.
We had a nice experience with that this year,
a film called "Rosita" which was the first American movie directed by Ernst Lubitsch,
one of the great directors in this medium.
And Mary Pickford, who was then the biggest
star in the world, invited Lubitsch to come
over from Germany in 1923 to direct her in
a film called "Rosita,"
which she subsequently kind of fell out of
love with,
even though it got great reviews at the time and was apparently quite successful.
She more or less abandoned it and allowed
her copy to dissolve.
But in the 1970s the head of the film collection,
a woman named Eileen Bowser found print
a print of this in the Soviet Film Archive and repatriated it.
It was printed in such terrible condition
we really didn't feel like there was anything
we could do with it until these new digital
tools appeared a few years ago.
And we were able to get a really good-looking
image out of this severely compromised
nitrate print.
We've shown it in a few festivals now with
a live orchestra and we hope to have that out
and available with a recorded score in
the very near future.
So it's something you might wanna keep an
eye out for.
Let's see...Natasha Giliberti, also from YouTube.
"How do you feel about the state of film right now?
Do you feel inspired by the work being made today?"
I feel good about the state of film right
now.
I think it's a time when a lot of new voices
are being heard.
It's becoming an inclusionary medium.
It was very exclusionary for years and years.
I personally don't spend as much time watching
new movies as I used to.
When that was my job I would see 8 or 10 new
movies a week.
These days, most of the work I'm doing is
with archival films, older films, so I don't
see that many new films.
But I'm always encouraged by the level of
activity that's going on out there, just the
hundreds and hundreds of films that are being
made and released.
I'm sure there's lots of exciting talents
there and I count on my fellow curators to
bring them to me because
I just don't have the time right now to sort through that great mass of material.
But again, it seems like a very exciting time
to be a filmmaker for me.
Suddenly new technologies make it possible
for features to be made on tiny, tiny budgets.
A lot of the old gatekeepers have fallen away,
and yeah, it's an exciting moment in film history.
We'll see which way it goes. Does it continue
to be feature-length films for theaters?
Does it merge into the television trend?
Nobody knows, so that makes it kind of exciting,
too.
It's a turning point moment, I think.
Many, many new developments going on and we
just don't know where they're going to lead quite yet.
Okay.
And gabiyank3e on Instagram asked, "How
instrumental is taste to curation?"
I think, as I said, it's kind of key.
You need your own sensibility.
You need your own approach to this big pile
of stuff that you're confronted with every day.
And the trick is not to keep your blinders
on, not to rely too much on your individual taste.
The danger of not being open to new forms
is really immediate, you know, and one that
I have found myself struggling with.
But nothing exists without that bedrock of
taste, and I think that bedrock of taste is
developed experientially.
You just have to watch and watch a lot of
movies.
You find your judgment improving, you make
comparisons almost subconsciously,
and your sense of what is good develops, changes over time.
And I hope that process never stops.
I hope I continue to shift my understanding
of this medium as it grows and branches out.
benglon on Instagram asks, "Which film first
got you interested in cinema and movies in general?"
And I have the most boring answer of all,
"Citizen Kane," Orson Welles.
I had always loved movies as a kid.
But "Citizen Kane," when I, in fact, probably
saw it I was maybe 10 or 12 years old was
the first one that made me think,
"People make these. There's a director there.
There's somebody making these choices and
making these images."
And that's what really got me excited.
It's in the realization that these things
aren't just handed down, that somebody has
to create them, and I became fascinated by
that.
Who were these people? Who were all those
names in front of the film?
I think a lot of people have an experience
with Orson because he's such a forceful personality,
such an immediate director.
But after you see some Orson Welles films
then you can start to appreciate, say,
Howard Hawks, or Yasujiro Ozu,
directors who don't have that kind of aggressive
style, are much more subtle or restrained.
It's what they're not doing that becomes expressive.
And yeah, that's always been my point of view
from very early on has been the director.
And I know for other people, I have good friends
who are interested pretty much entirely in
stars, tracing star careers.
I think that's a very valid approach, too.
People who are interested in the history of
a genre, the western and detective movie,
also a very valid approach.
Yeah, again, this is something you find
for yourself, I think, and you have to identify
your own interests and follow them out.
Someone named chezfoxyjam on Instagram wants
to know about MoMA's film still collection.
Does it ever go on view?
Well, I wish it could but it's several million
stills.
This is a gigantic collection, again, that
dates back to the mid '30s when MoMA started
collecting film material.
A big part of what we have is the photo files
from "Photoplay Magazine,"
which was kind of an upper middle brow publication
in the '20s and '30s and wasn't the scandal magazine
it became later.
But it was famous for featuring just beautiful
photography on every film, beautiful photography
of the stars.
We have just a gorgeous collection of original
large-format prints from that era,
and these things are stunning.
And there are just lots of them.
We haven't actually ever been able to do a complete catalog
of the film stills collection, and I don't
know if we ever will.
There are just so many of them.
Right now they all live in our film archive
out in Pennsylvania
but we make them available to researchers who can make an appointment through the moma.org website
and we will send for the photos you're interested
in and you can look them over in our Film Study Center.
But yeah, that's something we're very proud
of and we're very happy to be able to make
available to scholars and publishers.
And on Instagram, iyoweia asks, "How do you
select the topic and context to show?"
Yeah, also it's not a question of coming up
with abstract ideas mostly.
It's you get a sense of what's available,
what new restorations people are working on,
what studios might have, a new group of films
available.
We have just done a series of films made by
a poverty row studio called Republic Pictures
in the '30s, '40s, and '50s.
The studio has been out of business for years
but now the rights are owned by Paramount Pictures.
And they've spent a great deal of money making
nice new copies of a lot of these films, and
some very, very nice stuff that hasn't been
seen in years and years.
Martin Scorsese took in an interest in it
and has selected a group of 15 films that
will be showing starting in early August,
personal favorites of Mr. Scorsese's, most
of which have not been seen, at least in good prints,
for 30, 40 years now.
So that's the kind of opportunity you look
forward to and you really wanna jump on that
when it comes to you.
Where it gets complicated these days is that it's becoming harder and harder to find theatrical-grade prints,
by which I mean 35 millimeter or good digital
copies, high-resolution digital copies
that you can show in a large theater,
like the one you see here, and have the contrast
and the detail to really hold an audience's attention.
Those are becoming harder and harder to find.
Studios now are mostly interested in television
sales for those things.
They're not doing 35-millimeter prints any
longer.
The old prints are starting to wear out,
so it's becoming more and more difficult just to do a basic retrospective of director X, or actor Y.
You'll have big holes in your program, important
films that just will not be available, and
that's regrettable.
So yeah, you learn to program around that.
Luckily there's still plenty of choices out
there and plenty of programs we can do with
the things we can find and bring to our audience.
But I do feel that frustration when I can't
do...
well, I'd say Ida Lupino, very interesting director.
Not many of her films are currently available
in good 35-millimeter copies
or nicely produced digital editions.
We're working on one now that we have in our
collection, a film called "Never Fear."
We should have that available in a few months.
UCLA Film and Television Archive had done
a couple, the Library of Congress has done one or two,
and eventually we'll have critical
mass on Ida Lupino.
We'll be able to show her 15 films all together
at once.
People get an idea of what her accomplishment
was, I think the most gifted woman director
of the 1950s.
But we can't do it right now.
It's gonna take a little while longer until
we get those elements back together and
put them in the kind of shape that we can show
publicly.
Let's see, did this just come in?
Nuha Su on YouTube asks,
"Do you think that visual spectacle is taking priority over quality storytelling in mainstream cinema today?"
Yeah, I kind of do.
It seems like the narrative impulse is drifting
more toward those long-form television programs
and theatrical films are becoming more and more
about spectacle, about the special
effects, about the big sound.
Yeah, you know, certainly I miss the more
narrative, dramatic-driven storytelling in
theatrical films, but it's not like it has
vanished.
It's resurfaced in those long-form Netflix
and HBO series, and such like.
Again, this is a moment of sorting, I think,
in film culture.
New mediums that arise that can tell stories
in different ways.
Maybe the old mediums are receding a bit.
Again, this is something that we're gonna
have to pay very close attention to
for the next 5 or 10 years and you'll see what direction
things go in.
But it almost seems like that visual spectacle
that you're talking about is what people will
pay money to see.
That's what they'll put down their 10 or 12
bucks and go to a movie theater to see rocket ships,
and they won't spend that kind of money
to see a story.
Somehow the expectation is that that's what
you get on television for free these days,
and to me that's unfortunate.
But no point in being pessimistic because
these things are changing,
and again, I don't see that that impulse is being suppressed.
I think it's just being channeled in a different
direction now.
And well, here's a question about our restoration
of "Rosita" I was just talking about from
Annabelle Zakaluk.
"I just got the opportunity to see your restoration of 'Rosita' at the San Francisco Silent Film Festival!
Truly amazing."
Thank you very much.
"I have many friends who couldn't go, and
will you be releasing it on DVD or streaming?"
Indeed, this is something we are working on
right now.
Expectations have changed, I think, for, excuse
me, archives in the last few decades in that
MoMA was always oriented toward showing movies
basically in this room in a basement on West
53rd Street in New York City, and that was enough.
I mean, people had no wider expectations than
that.
But now that we live in an era of YouTube,
and streaming, and mass produced DVDs,
that doesn't feel like enough.
And I know there are lots of people certainly
watching this feed who
are not within striking distance of New York City,
and we are looking for ways to make our stuff
available to you, too.
It's not something we can do overnight because
we have to digitize the films in the collection,
which is an expensive and time-consuming process.
We have to figure out how to set up our streaming system,
or what kind of disc distribution if we end up doing that.
It won't be happening in the next few months
but I think it will be happening in the next few years.
We definitely are gonna make a more concerted
effort to get our work out in that form,
so hopefully we can share it with more people
than who just live in this zip code.
Instagram from michaelpaulphillips.
"Film is widely perceived as entertainment,
that being true in a lot of what is on the screen today.
Do you think film is a fundamental
tool with education purposes, and why?"
I think that's one thing that movies can do,
certainly, is educate.
I don't think it's the only thing they could
or should do.
I'm grateful that that's a medium that admits
to so many different uses,
so many different perspectives you can take.
Personally I don't much care for a didactic
cinema.
I like to be able to reach my own conclusions
about what the characters are doing or what
the politics of the situation might be.
But there are contexts where that's important.
We have a large collection of propaganda films
made during World War II made by the U.S. government,
and you can see some very stirring propaganda
pieces, which if they were employed in the...
put in the service of less credible ideologies
would be very disturbing, because that kind of
insistent, didactic tone is oppressive.
Yeah, you know, I'm not a person who likes
to make rules.
I'm not a person who's going to say, "The
movie can only do this, do that."
But certainly film can definitely teach.
And perhaps a good example of that are Frederick Wiseman's documentaries where he just
drops you into a situation,
the workings of a hotel, or a high school,
or a prison just for hours at a time.
And it's really left up to you to, again,
make sense of what you're seeing,
establish parallels,
see what this person is doing as opposed to
what that person is doing.
It never feels didactic, but certainly after
you've left a film like that you've learned
a lot about what that life is like, what that region is like, what that profession is like.
So to me, that's, yeah, educational in the
best way.
And from YouTube, Luis E R asks,
"What is the process of admitting a film into the museum's collection?"
It's actually a fairly formal process.
We have, what's called the film committee, which is a group of advisors and donors who meet
every two to three months,
to review films that have been proposed by
staff, by the curators,
whether or not we want to purchase those films, or accept them as gifts into the collection.
It's the same process that's used to acquire
painting and sculpture at the museum,
so it's something that's taken quite seriously.
It's not just anything that comes across the
transom is automatically accepted.
There's still a sense that if it's in the collection at the Museum of Modern Art that that means something,
and it definitely is true here.
Yeah, these works are vetted.
It's not a random collection.
It can certainly look that way if you looked at a list of what's being proposed at any given moment,
but we're fairly confident that a film gets into
the collection it's there for a good reason.
And a lot of people have looked at it, have passed on it, and we think it's something that
we wanna save for posterity
and we'll do our best to make sure that it is available for future generations.
So it's something we take very seriously.
And a live question from Mikhail S. on YouTube.
"Do you think that with the cinematic direction
of TV shows, specific episodes or whole TV
Definitely.
Again, relating to something we were talking
about earlier, we recently showed six episodes
of a TV series that Rainer Werner Fassbinder
did in the 1970s.
He did two other series and we've shown those
as well.
We have the structure to do that.
It's not something we do regularly, and again,
it's coming from the perspective of this is
what are we going to do about "The Sopranos,"
or something like that which is clearly
an important cultural event, current purview?
be changing the next few years is
And there are new examples of that all the time, so that remains very much an open question here and
it's something we'll be thinking about and
debating for years to come, I think.
But maybe it should.
Those are the first movies made in the United
States.
here and
I won't enter that debate, but we have some
of the first film that passed through his camera.
And here's Alvaro and Anastazia who are asking,
"What is the oldest film in MoMA's collection?"
Well, we have all of the movies that Thomas
Edison made in East Orange, New Jersey.
thanks to Iris Barry who acquired all the surviving negatives in the 1930s going up to the mid teens.
There's a lot of disputed claims about whether
those are the first movies period.
I won't enter that debate, but we have some
of the first film that passed through his
camera.
So that dates to, you know, 1893, 1895.
A guy named John D. Collins, who has really
been just discovered in the last two or three years
made movies between 1915 and 1919
to the mid teens.
A fantastic collection, and we're still working
on that.
Early film is its own thing, you know, very
interesting.
It takes a little more work because they don't
have all the tools that were developed later
but there were definitely some important artists
working in those films.
A guy named John D. Collins, who has really
been just discovered in the last two or three
years made movies between 1915 and 1919
when he died in the big flu epidemic that
year.
And he clearly would've been a major filmmaker,
but again, someone who was just unknown
South Africa, Rome, Los Angeles, Dubai, Montreal,
Bulgaria, Greece, Taiwan, and even New York City.
the collection at the George Eastman Museum
in Rochester and uncovered this work.
So it's a fascinating field and one I think
that's growing very quickly in academic circles.
And I feel a responsibility, I definitely
wanna get our movies out beyond our immediate area
So many, many things to look at, many things
to study.
Looks like we have a little note here about
the number of people who are tuning in.
We'll be in Venice the end of next month showing
a new restoration at the Venice Film Festival.
We'll actually be back in Italy in October
at the Pordenone Silent Film Festival,
a great film festival to show a brand new restoration of an Ernst Lubitsch film called "Forbidden Paradise."
"Rosita" will be in Australia next year, San Paolo next year, so we're starting to make some inroads out there.
I'm shocked, but very, very grateful that
you were able to join us for this session.
And I feel a responsibility, I definitely
wanna get our movies out beyond our immediate
So I think we're running out of time here, and I hope we've covered a few topics of interest to you,
and I would love to be able to show our films
in Greece, and Bulgaria, and South Africa.
in the comments section here on YouTube and
elsewhere.
We'll be in Venice the end of next month showing
a new restoration at the Venice Film Festival.
We'll actually be back in Italy in October
at the Pordenone Silent Film Festival,
a great film festival to show a brand new
restoration of an Ernst Lubitsch film called
We have a film playlist where we put together
all of our how-to-see videos that we talked about today.
"Rosita" will be in Australia next year, San
Paolo next year, so we're starting to make
some inroads out there.
and we'll have a link for that in the description
below.
And if we didn't get to your question during
this session  please post them again and we'll
So I think we're running out of time here,
and I hope we've covered a few topics of interest
to you,
and I definitely appreciate all the great
questions and comments you've been leaving
in the comments section here on YouTube and
elsewhere.
And if you enjoyed this video we'd like to
urge you to check out the other videos we
But certainly a film can definitely, definitely teach.
drops you into a situation,
It's not a random collection.
Here's Alvaro and Anastazia who are asking,
"What is the oldest film in MoMA's collection?"
For more on the history of film at the Museum
of Modern Art you can check out the new film
portal on MoMA Learning,
and we'll have a link for that in the description
below.
And if we didn't get to your question during
this session please post them again and we'll
try to get to those in the next few days.
So thanks for tuning in.
Please keep sending us questions and let us
know if you wanna see more of these things,
and subscribe so you don't miss our next offering.
And again, thanks very much, hope to see you
next time.